okay good morning it's 9 20 so i will
kick off so this is rendering
3d worlds in c-sharp and i suppose this
talk is a
play in 4x we're gonna think a lot about
the history of 3d graphics and we're
going to think about the history of
games before we see some code
there's quite a lot to get through so if
you've got any questions
i'll grab them probably at the end or on
slack
unless they're about maths then i'll
probably refer you to wikipedia i say
only
half joking cool so let me talk about me
a little bit
obviously all about me i'm david and i'm
an
independent software consultant based in
london
in the uk i work for myself
mostly taking roles mentoring developers
and
doing strategic work for biguk.coms
i've done a variety of jobs with
variably pretentious titles like head of
engineering and chief technical
architect
head principal engineer which all sounds
a lot fancier than it
really is i i just love making things
and i love the people that make things
and i try and spend time helping them
and doing cool stuff so
i've written a couple of kids books
about programming websites and games in
javascript
and available uh all regional languages
and all good bookstores get coding one
and two plug
but recently just kind of to see if i
could i built a 3d renderer in
raw c-sharp
so why
why on earth why why would you do that
so i know it's all a little bit
pointless really
but isn't that the fun of
experimentation
there are lots of different answers to
this question but firstly i really just
wanted to see if i could do it
so often we're forced to live in this
brutalistic
corporate hell hole where the only
things that have to exist
exist for money and those are the only
things that ever get rendered into
reality
so this is kind of the opposite of that
so 3d engines exist
if you want to build a game you probably
shouldn't do anything i'm
going to do in this talk it'll be a
waste of time and effort
you should go and download unity or
unreal engine and make your awesome game
but if you want to do silly things to
see what you're capable of
come with me on this journey i'm not a
graphics programmer
and i came to this topic pretty cold
before we get going i just want to
caveat a few things about sequencing and
history so in a talk like this we're
going to be talking about technological
advancement from a period where things
were being invented and reinvented over
and over again
i'm going to be talking about things in
sequence here that appear to have come
after
other things but in all practicality
we're probably being worked on
simultaneously
that every single game i mention
there were doubtless other games that
came before
or they were riffing on a similar theme
or they were influenced by
peers in their local communities so
please do not feel slighted if i forget
to mention
your favorite game i'm totally
absolutely sure it's awesome and
important and legitimately amazing
before we deep dive into 3d it's
important to understand
what three-dimensional images what 3d
actually means your computer monitors
are all
two-dimensional even if you're using vr
headsets they're
two-dimensional they literally have two
axes
an x and a y axis they render flat
images
so when you try and draw by hand
something that looks 3d
on a 2d space it often looks strange and
wrong
the screenshot here from rampage an old
game is
is 2d it's clearly trying to represent a
3d space
but no one no one would look at this and
say oh god that's a that's a really well
rendered 3d
image it's not even pseudo 3d
because there are only two planes left
to right and up and down in this image
it's not to scale
it's definitely not 3d
it's all really a matter of perspective
so
making a two-dimensional image
three-dimensional
is not actually about the fidelity of
the image as
some people mistakenly think people
think that it's all about quality
but actually it's about how an image
captures perspective
and perspective is an art technique for
creating the illusion of 3d
on a 2d surface so the correct
use of perspective actually was one of
the great inventions of 15th century art
it's often credited to lyon batista
alberti in a book he wrote called
wonderfully titled on painting
which dates to 1435 the year 1435
alberti outlined what is now known as
linear perspective
and what linear perspective does is it
plots a single horizon line with a
vanishing point
and it positions elements along those
lines heading towards the vanishing
point to simulate
depth linear perspective though
is is just one kind of projection
so that's the reason that both the
picture at the top and the bottom there
seem 3d it's because they're capturing
perspective
so a projection
is a graphical technique that maps
three-dimensional points
into two-dimensional space
it's an engineering and fine art
discipline actually and and can be
learned so this is not the same
as being a great painter it's a
technical discipline
it's a mathematical exercise and
projections come in many many forms
all defined by where the camera is
supposed to be i use the word camera
loosely where the
the viewer is supposed to be and where
the focal points are placed in the image
accurate perspective projections are
what make something
look three-dimensional in a
two-dimensional space
converting those three axes
into two axes
so one point perspective is the most
common three-dimensional projection in
games today
it's the first person shooter
perspective with a single camera from
the focal point of a main character
over time though games have used other
perspectives for various reasons
early games often favored orthographic
perspectives
the isometric rendering of 3d into 2d
we'd still i suppose consider these
games 2d games
but they were technically representing
three-dimensional space
they were technically 3d games but it's
not what people really mean when they
say true 3d
isometric perspective is really really
useful in games especially in older
games
because all the objects inside the 3d
space
remain the same size wherever they occur
and in early games scaling things in
size was computationally really
expensive
so being able to write a single to
design a single art asset
that you could move around the pseudo 3d
space without scaling without changing
without swapping it out for another
asset
because there was no storage space was
really important
it's worth remembering that when we talk
about 3d today what we're really
referring to is polygonal 3d
and actually gaming has this rich
history of pre-polygonal 3d graphics
that are worth considering along with
the journey we took towards high
performance
polygonal 3d
so this is a screenshot from the very
recent unreal
engine 5 demo it's due out in 2021
sometime
and you really have to marvel at the
absolute
beauty and sheer weight of research and
technical excellence behind this
screenshot
there are literally billions of polygons
in this image
millions of polygons on each rock
each decorated with 4k scan textures
mapped onto those objects
there's global illumination modeled rays
of light that bounce off surfaces
we've got depth of field effects
particle effects
material simulations most of which are
implemented in pixel shaders that run on
specialist cpu cores called gpus
that are optimized for crunching maths
modern 3d is the accumulation of three
decades of work
in polygonal 3d rendering the fact that
we can
make images with this degree of fidelity
is actually mind-blowing is it
it's it's amazing i saw a joke floating
around the internet which is something
like
oh epic games are building unreal engine
5 to shame web devs
who struggle to make websites run at 30
frames a second
and i suppose a little bit truth in that
but really to appreciate modern 3d it's
important to grasp the road that we
traveled
to the destination
i want us to appreciate some of the
things that you might not think were
really 3d
but secretly kind of really were on the
way
so on the left we have tempest
and on the right we have maze war
long before general purpose 3d way back
in the 1970s
we have what appeared to be 3d graphics
in vector-based games
and i want this to really challenge our
idea of what being 3d really means
so obviously tempest isn't 3d that's a
2d game
but if we look at the screenshot of maze
war
this is technically the first
three-dimensional first-person shooter
it was written in 1973 running on a
pds-1 computer in the screenshot
and it was made up of what appears to be
empty hollow polygons but it was
actually something very very different
so these polygons didn't really exist in
the game code
they were the result of line drawing
operations on vector monitors
and vector monitors are super
interesting because they're not like the
displays we use today a vector monitor
is not divided into pixels like a modern
display
it's instead instead it has more in
common with the displays on an
oscilloscope
it technically has infinite resolution
so this was a trend that continued into
the early 80s
in fact and you know at the top here we
have a relatively well-known
star wars game from i think 1983
and battle zone underneath so
the surface of a vector display screen
is a single layer of phosphor
it emits light wherever the electron gun
hits it
this meant that if programmers were
creative enough they could manually in
their code and struck the display to
draw whatever shapes they wanted
just as if they were drawing lines on
paper
games like tempest asteroid and the
early star wars arcade game here
and games consoles like the vectrex
managed to look way ahead of their time
in some respects they were a natural
evolution from the very first video game
which was called tennis for two
which was actually played on an
oscilloscope and it was i suppose a
proto-pong
game the vetrex itself actually was a
fascinating console
it was born of a smith engineering
employee working out a way to clear
their stocks of surplus
crt vector-based displays they found a
bunch of
one-inch high displays that were
originally manufactured for medical use
there was only actually one single run
of the consoles because then they ran
out of cheap screens
which as a result makes them relatively
expensive collectors items today
but they did things like pen
digitization they
actually really ahead at the time very
cool
during the 70s and early 80s there was
actually this broad
shift towards resto graphics displays
and you may have heard the terms vector
graphics and raster graphics but let's
unpack what that really means
so compared to a vector display where
you could draw anything
anywhere raster displays use bitmapped
graphics
what that means is that the display is
divided into pixels
usually directly mapped to an area of
memory
so rather than the effective infinite
resolution of a vector display
raster displays operate set resolutions
you've all used them you're literally
using them right now
that the screens you know and love
raster displays provided a level of
hardware abstraction
over the low level drawing of vector
displays
vector displays had to be redrawn
repeatedly to keep the image on the
screen
where rester was predictable with fixed
refresh rates and easier to standardize
over
so raster displays were common going all
the way back to pong in 1972 in games
use arrester display for instance
and over time the use of vector displays
became less and less common
with the arcade industry using raster
displays by the eighties almost
exclusively
there were obviously notable exceptions
like the star wars game on the previous
slide
but the games of the 80s that featured
3d often used
artistic technique to simulate 3d which
is really just a raster graphics
approach to the earlier line drawing 3d
vector graphics games just this time in
higher fidelity with richer colors
because vector displays could only
support up to three colors with special
films
occasionally like in the case of atari's
irobot in the top left here
no relation to the film or the book
specialized hardware was actually built
into the arcade cabinets
to support drawing polygons quickly this
this arcade machine had a custom
3d coprocessor which you could really
think of as the
progenitor of the 3d accelerator market
so pictured here we have i robot we have
falcon
and we have lucasarts rescue on
fractalus
bottom left which was seen as the first
game to ever legitimately scare people
when you
encountered aliens and didn't know if
they were friendly or not
we then entered this era of sega
superscalar
series of arcade boards so these these
are cables powered games like space
harrier
afterburner sega have become adept at
sprite-based pixel art
in their prior arcade games and they've
started on this journey towards texture
mapped 3d
by implementing hardware sprite scaling
to provide
perspective so this kind of fast sprite
scaling was far beyond the capabilities
of home consoles in the mid-80s
they introduced the what they called the
superscalar rk graphics technology
with hang on in 1985. the the guy that
designed these boards you suzuki very
very famous sega designer
is quoted as saying that the superscalar
games were designed as 3d games
and then simulated using sprite scaling
to produce the look of checks your map
3d
and as a result they they looked way
more impressive than early polygonal 3d
graphics
sega were great at art
in fact superscalar technology was
astonishingly similar to the very very
hyped
mode 7 graphics mode on the super
nintendo so mode 7
included hardware support to scale and
rotate
the background layer only of sprites on
a scan line by scan line basis
so if you ever played on the snares
you'll recognize this as the way that
the
race course effect if you actually you
look at the screenshots ignore star fox
that was something different
but f zero pilot wings and mario kart
the thing they all have in common
is the background is a single skewed 2d
sprite
that rotates around a fixed point it's
the foundation of their graphics engines
and you know they use hardware sprite
scaling in tons of games
it looked really cool at the time
so the funny thing is sega were so good
at scaling and rotating sprites
that it actually formed the foundation
of their sega saturn console they
released in 1994.
it was actually very similar to the
final superscalar arcade boards in
hardware design
so digital foundry the the youtube
channel did an excellent
uh retro game retrospective on the game
tomb raider
where they used an emulator to unskew
the saturn's
quad-based rendering engine which
actually favored over polygons
so as you can see in the top screenshot
here what that really meant
is 3d games on the sega saturn were
actually 2d
square sprites skewed and mapped over
the polygons
to generate textures around the game
world
ironically this gave the saturn its
reputation for being hard to program and
probably contributed to its defeat at
the end of the sony playstation which
made a large bet
on true polygonal 3d i find the
screenshot amazing
and then we hit the early 90s and in the
early 90s there was this slow and
lumbering lurch
into true polygonal 3d and they were
really
really rough honestly like all the way
until the mid 90s
early 3d was exceptionally low poly
meaning that the 3d models the hardware
at the time could cope with were low in
complexity
the engines were slow and the art style
possible with the really crude forms of
3d rendering at the time was
really really rough like this stuff has
not aged well at all
in fact given the relative quality of
truth 3d
in the early 90s you can perhaps
understand
what sega was thinking when they were
designing the saturn
they were kind of unwilling to dispose
of two decades with a 2d experience
so quickly especially when their pseudo
3d was
kind of plenty fast and looked nice
that said sega themselves took the first
stab at true 3d with virtua racing and
this was in the august 1992
which was initially a proof of concept
for exercising a new 3d graphics
platform they called the model 1.
the late 80s had seen a few polygonal
titles from
atari and namco but none with the poly
count and performance of sega's model on
board
they followed up virtual racing with
virtua fighter which went on to become
another
huge hit and ubiquitous and arcades
everywhere
so while there were plenty of games
reaching for real 3d at the time
it was probably the mixture of mario 64
in september of 96
tomb raider in october of 96 and quake
in june of 1996
that really solidified what polygonal 3d
games could actually be
sega saturn had shipped with home ports
of virtual racing and virtual fighting
very late in 94.
but it wasn't until the release the
playstation the n64
that the scene was really set for the
mid to late 90s 3d game explosion
with those first games that felt like
they really made complex 3d games
mainstream there were plenty of other
games doing 3d
between 1994 and 1996. but it's easy to
remember
just how ropey some of the game design
and conventions were
because this was entirely new territory
for game designers
so these these 3d games really these
three games even really lock down some
of the conventions
of gaming that stick around today so
we're talking about 3d
camera control first person perspectives
and interactivity
of these three tomb raiders probably
aged the worst
and this is due to some unfortunate
control scheme choices
made at a time when there were literally
no default control schemes for 3d
games mario 64 is still as playable
today as ever
and quake holds up entirely as the first
real 3d networked multiplayer game that
worked a bit of a quick recap before we
go on
we've talked about three ways of
simulating 3d
through early video game arcade industry
titles
there was vector line drawing that
projected 3d
there was early orthographic projections
to render isometric viewpoints
and there was sprite scaling to simulate
3d models
and then finally true 3d polygons
but what i've not spoken about much as
speed
and we've not even touched on the home
computer market at the time
so there's kind of a parallel thread
here and that's 1990s pc gaming
the personal computer existed in an
alternate universe from
games development for consoles and
arcades at the time
the ibm pc standardized in the early 80s
but wasn't really seen as a thing for
play
it was targeted towards business users
and we're still at the end of the 1980s
microcomputer trend here
especially in the uk so we have systems
like the atari st and the commodore
amiga being much more common in the home
at the time
so that's not to say that there weren't
games on the pc in the 1980s
but the kind of games you saw were often
slow occasionally text based and not
very similar to the games popular on
consoles at the time
you'd expect to see adventure games like
the king's quest series
elite loadrunner the zork trilogy text
based games that's what people thought
about when they thought of pc games
slow laborious point-and-click
adventures and simulations
not graphically rich fast-paced games
like mario or sonic
it was kind of conventional wisdom that
pcs literally were not capable of the
kind of performance
the more specialized gaming systems were
but i want to tell you about a game
that's secretly really really important
so in 1991 a company called soft disk
put out the game hover tank 3d
as part of their gamers edge series of
monthly disks
so this is a series curated by a man
called john romero
soft disc have made a name for
themselves as part of the burgeoning
shareware scene
and this is one of just the many games
they put out
they described it like this hover tank
3d is set during a nuclear war
the player controls brick sledge a
mercenary hired by an unknown
organization
to rescue people from cities under the
threat of nuclear attack
largely by political activists or
scientists oh how relevant
both by the government and by large
corporations however the cities are also
full of mutated humans strange creatures
armed guards and enemy hover tanks of
course okay so this sounds like it could
literally be any other game of the year
right but hover tank 3d was a little bit
more important than that
surprise is john karmic so the four
people that were working on gamer's edge
at the time
were john carmack john romero adrian
carmackner relation
and tom hall these people were gone to
be the four founders of the prolific
game studio id software
and all these are wonderful 90s photos
i especially like the really the romance
novel vibe
and in the photo of the right that's
totally my gem um
in their evenings while working at soft
disc these
gorgeous beautiful men were taking their
work computers home with them
and working on what would later become
the id software games
so the team had just cloned super mario
bros 3 for the pc
so this was something at the time that
was deemed completely impossible
nobody thought screw smooth scrolling
could reach the performance of the nez
original
on pc hardware in the mid 90s sorry in
mid 1990
this slide is actually a screenshot from
that specific pc port that john romero
put online i think for the
25th or 30th anniversary
they had sat for a week tracing
literally with pen and paper
the original game on a crt television
cloning its gameplay
so they sent it to nintendo who politely
declined the port
not only that they told them they
couldn't use it so
that led to them building and releasing
a game called commander keen
am suspiciously 2d side-scrolling
platformer where you jumped on enemies
with smooth scrolling on the
pc yeah not not suspicious at all
uh in in another world super mario bros
3 might have been released on the pc
and we may have never played any of the
future id software games
so hover tank 3d was the game they built
to follow commander keane
and it was their first 3d engine it took
six weeks to build
and compared to other pseudo 3d engines
at the time it was really really fast
so the reason it's really important is
it was the game engine that would go on
to form the prototype of the wolfenstein
3d
game engine which later would become the
foundation of the tech behind the game
doom it would go on to develop quake
its sequels rage a load more doom games
carmack eventually goes on to serve as
the cto of oculus vr
and does civilian rocket flight these
games were renowned for their speed
it's what made them playable and
addictive along with
being able to pioneer online multiplayer
game modding open sourcing games all
because of these engines
and part of the reason these games run
so well
is because of how their graphics engines
worked and how they worked around the
hardware constraints at the time
so doom uses a technique called bsp
binary space petitioning for its
rendering and we're not going to deep
dive into that here
what we're going to do is we're going to
start with wolfenstein 3d and take a
look at how it's 3d renderer works
if you're interested in more information
on the history of id software there's a
really great book about it by a guy
called david kushner
called the masters of doom from 2003
it's on
kindle amazon bonds noble good
bookstores
it's a really fun read and it's an
interesting story through
the history of arcades in the early pc
gaming scene i would recommend it it's
fun
so there are only two things you really
need to know about making things run
fast in 3d render as little as possible
and do maths really really quickly
i half joke but it's kind of as true in
2020 as it was in 1991.
the games industry today is full of
clever optimization techniques to work
out how to render the absolute least
things possible and we're going to take
a look at a technique called raycasting
which was the basis of both the
hovertank 3d and wolfenstein 3d game
engines
you know you could tell it was new at
the time because they stuck 3d in both
of the game titles
it was an early approach that was used
to make things run fast
so i will refer to wikipedia
raycasting is the use of ray surface
intersection tests to solve a variety of
problems in 3d computer graphics and
computational geometry
the term was first used in computer
graphics in 1982
in a paper by scott roth to describe a
method for rendering constructive solid
geometry models i always wonder who
writes those really really faux sciency
descriptions on wikipedia
wolf 3d uses raycasting to convert a 2d
level design a flat maze this is one of
the maps in wolfenstein
into a 3d projection and we're going to
dissect and clone this behavior in code
so how could we convert that map this
real wolf 3d map
into a 3d world that we can run around
so i've drawn a really crude map on this
slide
it's a big empty room with two blocks
inside of it
towards the bottom of the map i've drawn
a circle
which represents our camera facing north
if we were to imagine that our camera
was casting rays literally drawing
straight
lines for every part of its field of
view
it might look something like the lines
drawn from our camera point
so the number of rays we're casting here
isn't that important
but in a real world example it'd be
related to the focal length of a camera
so the further array has to travel from
its origin the camera
before it makes contact with something
further away that thing is so we have
eight rays
in in our example here
now imagine that we record the distance
that each of our rays travels and fill
up some columns
the further array travels the fewer
pixels we fill up in our column
so our first ray was really close to
this left-hand block that you can see in
the top right there
so we fill up quite a lot of pixels
the second ray is clipping
the side of our left hand block again we
fill up quite a lot of pixels a little
bit less than the first ray the third
through the sixth rays are shooting way
off into the distance
before they make contact with a surface
at the very back of the room so we're
filling up
almost no pixels at all
and once we reach our seventh and eighth
rays we're connecting with the right
hand block
again and filling up our columns
so represented like this this doesn't
look like much of anything these are
just crude hand drawings and they're not
very accurate
it doesn't look like 3d but allow me to
perform a magic trick
if we take our column of pixels we fill
them vertically
and center them making sure that
there's the same amount of space equally
divided above and below our pixels
hey look we that looks like a 3d world
so it's got a wall in the far distance
there's some blocks on our left and
right that are near to us
and this is fundamentally how ray
casting works in practice
you shoot a number of rays scanning from
left to right
and you measure the distance they travel
before they connect to the surface
if the surface is solid the rays stops
and if the surface isn't it can continue
to travel and connect with other
surfaces
so this approach is faster than other
rendering techniques
that order objects on their z index how
far away from the camera something is
and then render them furthest away
objects first which was one of the
competing techniques at the time
this approach while absolutely fine it
requires multiple passes over pixels to
correctly construct the image
so you end up drawing again and again
over the top of things it's not very
performance optimized
whereas this just requires a single
line of horizontal rays
it's quite fast what we do is we set a
max range on our camera
so our rays simply give up if they don't
make contact with
anything far off into the distance so we
can now express the number of pixels in
any given column
as a percentage of that total distance
at the max range of our camera
we calculate the percentage of vertical
pixels to fill up
as the distance traveled divided by the
camera range times 100
by doing this calculation and measuring
the distance array travels
and by knowing the target height of our
screen
we can easily calculate how many pixels
to draw
so by doing this we project our 2d plane
into 3d space
we've looked at how we can use
raycasting to determine the distance
between an arbitrary camera
and surfaces in the 2d space but how do
we practically how do we really turn
this into an image
so the simplest way possible
is we cast a single ray for each and
every horizontal pixel of our target
output
image so in our worked example
previously we're only considering eight
rays that we cast
it's not computationally too expensive
though to just cast
more so for a target resolution of
1024x768
we'd cast 1024 rays
one for each horizontal pixel similarly
for a resolution of 1920 by 1080 a full
hd image
we cast 1920 rays
so let's let's build our own 3d engine
let's let's do the thing
we can do this i suppose
this is kind of a net conference not a
history of video games graphics session
so i should probably show you some code
what we're going to do is we're going to
define our own map format
we're going to write the simplest
raycaster i can fit into some slides
and we're going to do one or two bits of
scary looking maths
for someone like me when i say someone
like me i mean someone that stopped
studying meths
at 16 and then finally we're going to
render our own 3d world
so when you consider this our finest
3d game level we're going to be
astounded by our two games
our two cubes in a room i can just feel
the cover shooter gameplay brewing right
now i hear you yell
this is gears of war 20.
so this is a bog standard file
new project default.net core 3.1
console application i've added two
static variables
max camera range which i've set to 50
and the world's most glorious string
array called
what we're going to do is we're going to
put our level data into that string
array
using my innovative new data storage
format
i've got a name for it it's called
hashes for walls coming 2021
to take the gaming world by storm for
the sake of this example
any space a literally any space
character
has a height of zero and any hash
has a height of one i know innovative
we're also setting up a camera location
as a location 2d type so this is just a
struct
that contains two properties x and y
there is nothing else going on in there
the camera is going to be located 10
characters in and seven rows down
in our array facing to the right by
default
which i think puts it about here
so our ray what's array how do we
express array
our ray is just a list of sample points
a sample point has a location that it's
sampling
here along with storing the length of
this part of the ray
here and the total distance traveled to
get to this location
here the idea is
that as we write code to walk through
our map we're just going to append a new
sample point to this list as we go on
the final sample point is always going
to be the one that connects with a
surface
so it will always be the last sample
point in our array
you'll notice we have a property in the
sample point called surface
here in our map we only actually have
two kinds of surfaces a wall or nothing
and when we detect a surface later on
we're going to store a reference to the
surface that we're detecting here
so there's a lot going on here and i
want to walk through really slowly
we're going to create a new result an
array of sample points
exactly the width of our desired
rendered image
remember each horizontal picture needs a
picture pixel needs a ray casting
we're then going to perform a for loop
for each pixel in our target horizontal
resolution
and shoot array
we work out our x value the angle of the
ray that we want to cast
by taking our column number and dividing
it by the render width and subtracting
0.5
this works out exactly where we're
pointing our our ray
on our plane
it effectively takes the desired camera
angle splits it into columns and
positions the camera in the center
of the column we've calculated the
location of
we create our origin sample points
at the location of our camera
and then we're going to work out which
direction to cast our
ray let's zoom down a bit
so this is one of those mass things that
you weren't paying attention to in
school
don't worry neither was i i had to look
this up at age 35.
so a radian is a standard unit of
angular measure
it describes how many degrees around a
full circle that you are
here these radians so the direction in
degrees that we want to cast
our ray to is pi divided by 180
times the direction degrees of our
camera
so that get computes our radians this
actually
should be called direction in radians i
think um
and what we're doing is we're returning
a cast direction object
which we create from this final output
which works out which way we're pointing
on this circle
so a little bit more maths that you
might have been sleeping through in high
school
our cast direction object contains the
sine and the cosine
of the direction we provided that we
expressed in radians
now remember that radians are just
a maths word for what direction on the
circle are we pointing
so sine and cosine are two of the main
functions used in trigonometry
and they calculate the ratio of sides of
a right angle triangle
in our case they're going to help us
work out how far to the left
and how far to the right we're going to
cast our rays from our starting point
all the code so this is the core of our
ray casting algorithm
what we do is we loop forwards
infinitely walking one step
following the shortest path the ray can
take now you could express this
with recursion but a while true loop is
easier to comprehend here
what we do is we use the sine and the
cosine
along with the current x and y value to
calculate
what the length of one step forward
would be on both the x and the y axis
so we call this function twice and you
if you notice carefully
we flip cos and sin here and y and x and
x and y
we compare the length of each step and
we choose the shortest path
once we know which it is once we
pick the shortest step we call a
function
or a method even called inspect telling
it to either shift
one x or one y
inspect returns a sample point which we
which will keep a reference to any
detected surfacing
if this if the surface has no height
well we just we continue we
loop onwards if we're at our max camera
depth
we return the ray path in its entirety
and if we reach something with height
amazing we found a surface so we store
our current sample points at the end of
our
list and we return our complete traced
path
so let's take a look into how we
determine what the next step to take is
this next step on the line
so what this block of confusing looking
code does is
given an angle in degrees and a pair of
coordinates
it calculates the next step forward
along our line
we call it with the sine and cosine
values that we created in
that were held inside our cast direction
object and this feels really messy
and it was certainly an eyeful when i
first tried working it out here
so what we're doing is to calculate an x
next step we take our cosine value which
we call run
and if it's greater than one add one if
it's less
we subtract one so we're kind of walking
through a 2d array
this is inverted when we call the
methods for our y step with the sine
value becoming the run
and the y value having one added or
subtracted from it
we record this change in length and we
generate a new location 2d coordinate
if the first value is x we just return
that location
because it's not inverted if we've
called this function with our sine and
cosine x and y inverted
we just call this little flip x y
extension method which just literally
flips that makes
x equal to y and y equal to x
there are likely prettier ways to
express this concept it's a bit of a
a mind bender but that's what i have for
the moment so we're going to run with it
our inspect method shifts either
x or y by one depending on if x or y was
the shortest path
when it was called so it calls the
detect
surface function which converts our
double
down into an integer so we've got a
position here
on our grid and we want to convert it to
literally x y coordinates in our string
array
and then we call our surface hat
function which just checks by grabbing
y x it grabs a single character from our
string array
and if it's a hash it returns a surface
with a height of one
otherwise it returns nothing so these
values are then consumed by the loop
backup and the ray function which
evaluate this response to work out
whether the ray is collided with the
surface or not
in a more comprehensive implementation
of this
other characters could return surfaces
of varying heights
and rays could continue onwards past
things that were only partially
obstructing the view
rather than in our implementation here
where we just stop as soon as we reach a
surface
even in in our cool map format of hashes
for walls
different characters could be used to
return different surfaces with different
characteristics
which could correlate to different
visual textures
so after casting our rays we have a
total distance value for each point on
our horizontal axis
but we need to do a little bit more work
to convert this to an image
that might look like something
i've actually split these steps into two
to make them a little bit more
explicable
but you could merge both our cast rays
function here that scans across and our
render bitmap method if you really
wanted to
the bitmap renderer is responsible for
taking our array of completed rays
and working out how many pixels to fill
up in each of our vertical columns like
we did by hand earlier
we're then going to write the bitmap to
a memory stream and save it to disk so
i can open it in an image editor there's
literally nothing interesting here at
all
um and we're gonna we're gonna dive into
our height calculations now
so this looks very scary at a glance but
it's not that bad
so firstly our image width and image
height
we're gonna just use say 1024x768 in
this case a standard
if small in 2020 resolution
so first we're going to create a new
image using the wonderful image sharp
library
really really great library and we're
going to set
the desired width and height so image
sharp
is an open source image manipulation
library written in pure c-sharp
it doesn't rely on any legacy interop
it's fully cross-platform
unlike many of the legacy image
manipulation apis we've had access to in
dot net before and we're going to loop
around each sample point in our column
so the the column integer here is also
our x coordinate
in our output image
what we're going to do is we're going to
work out the number of pixels we need to
fill in
so the max possible height is the image
height times the surface height
in our example either 0 or 1
and then we work out the height as a
percentage of the
distance traveled and also here dividing
distance traveled by
2.5 this just means that our walls can
be a little bit taller
in the output image you can you don't
need this here it just felt
better when i actually saw this with my
eyes
and then we're calculating our vertical
padding
so this is the space above and below the
pixels in each column
that don't contain our surface
we're taking our full image height
subtracting the height of our pixels
and dividing by two so
now we get to loop over our y-axis
starting at the vertical padding number
to skip the top portion of the image and
then we loop
up to the image height minus our
vertical padding to skip
the bottom portion of our buffer and
we basically are just leaving the same
amount of space at the top and bottom of
the image by writing this loop
and then we're just filling in
in our in our new image here we're
filling it in with a texture so
i'm kind of cheating here so the texture
is just
the red green blue value 200 200 200
a kind of murky white horrible color
honestly so it's very very difficult to
visualize what this is doing so why
don't i just
show you like how cool is that
oh my god like we have a ray traced
image
sorry raycast not raytraced image in our
output directory this is this is that
code
it felt like a bit of a long journey but
we're actually still inside 200 lines of
code in total here
and we've only done like three bits of
maths literally
you can see our walls projected towards
our focal point in the distance
and we've got our two blocks that's some
aaa game design right there
two blocks standing there in white well
murky off-white
so i don't like the fact that this just
looks flat i want to update our code to
call a new select texture method
so we're going to do some really quick
back of the envelope methods here
entry rgb 200 200 200 are off white
as the maximum brightness that we can
render and basically inventing global
illumination
and it's murky gray the further away the
wall is from the camera
the dimmer that we make the pixels and
what this does is it kind of simulates
fading off into the distance
in a real game engine we'd likely use
this function to look up
a texture and map pixels from a source
texture on and project them onto the
the walls we're creating but for now
flat colors are going to
work for us so this is
relatively simplistic we just work out a
percentage of the total 200 and we set
our rg and b values to it that's all
we're doing
so let's take a look
look at that i love it it's a black and
white image
that represents our string array map
rendered into 3d
with our own raycaster so
we're doing a projection of a
two-dimensional
axis into three-dimensional space that's
pretty cool
i like it i love it
so let's talk about floors and ceilings
so it's really it's probably quite
apparent that if i only have a 2d array
i don't really have any textures for the
floor or the ceiling there's no notion
of height
which actually there was no height in
wolfenstein there was no height and doom
it was all simulated so see this
gradient
i like this gradient very much thank you
thank you i made it in a minute or two
in paint.net
my finest gradient work it might not
seem like much but it's mine
so the reason i love this gradient is i
can use it to cheat
and provide additional texturing to the
floor and ceiling of my raycaster
while literally writing one line of code
well two i suppose instead of creating
our world from a blank image
and then filling in the pixels over the
top of it all i'm going to do is just
load this gradient into my bitmap before
we render the world
and i'm going to resize it to the
resolution
of our target image and it'll come out
looking like we had a floor and ceiling
all along i mean i could possibly put
carpet down and a blue sky
so it's especially sneaky because our
world is still technically
a 2d plane projected into 3d
but it's exactly how all the games
worked they cheated always cheap
see doesn't that just feel a little bit
more real
this is a screenshot of obviously a
slightly higher resolution render
and what i did is i crammed the renderer
into a wim forms ui wim forms represent
so i could hook up keyboard controls
like you'll probably laugh
but it's just a picture box control and
all i'm doing is
taking the byte array of the bitmap and
setting the bitmap in the picture box
60 times a second in there but you know
what like i've got 60 frames a second
playable uh big room with two blocks
good enough to play with you know
wire up controls in wim forms is a
simple task
i'm just subscribing to the on key down
event
that comes built into winforms and
adjusting the location 2d
property and my camera to add first
person style wasd
controls i think i literally spent 15
minutes in total
hooking these bits up into wim forms
just so i could have fun swinging my
camera around in real time
a switch statement that updates a a
property
is is all it took i was kind of almost
alarmed at how simple it was
there is a sneaky little bit of maths
hiding at the top there though
which calculates the movement delta for
each keypress or mouse movement
it relies on using the same co sine and
cosine
operations to work out which way we
should swing the camera based on the
left and right and up and down offsets
of the pixels or keys
and there's a magic number of 0.35 which
felt right
which i i suppose technically is a mouse
sensitivity option
i also crammed it into a razor pages
file
i literally pasted all the code into the
code behind
and stuck a web form in front of it and
the really fun thing about this demo
is that it lets you edit the map in the
text box and then just
put a number in for the camera angle and
click submit and it will render a new
world in your web browser
i mean honestly i just did it to see if
i could to see if it would work
so there are plenty more places that
that we can take this prototype
it's missing texture mapping on the
walls but we have a place for it in our
code
we could implement surfaces that don't
occupy 100 of the height
of the space that they're encountering
so we could put half height walls in and
really build gears of war we could
implement different surfaces like glass
materials
that the rays continue traveling through
and then
you combine the colors of the pixels the
ray encounters as it passes through them
this code really isn't performance
optimized and realistically it's not the
kind of code you write if you were
building a 3d game today
but to me it's an interesting curiosity
it's a technique from a more resource
constrained time
the languages we have today are
certainly capable of doing what was
significantly harder
then in a lot less code if you want to
build games today in c
sharp use unity use unreal engine with
c-sharp bindings
use mono game but i hope you've enjoyed
coming on this journey with me
just how old games hung together
you can get the code so the code for
this
is available in a gist here
paste it play with it have fun quick
screenshot it
because there's some more slides i'm
gonna
conspicuously wait for like a minute so
anyone can write that down if they need
to
i will paste it in the slack in slack
afterwards don't worry
so the most obvious question when we're
talking about ray casting
is hey is this the same as ray tracing
on my gpu
well sort of
this is an incredibly scaled back
example of casting rays
the modern version of which is more
often called ray tracing
and the terms were used interchangeably
at one point in history
but they definitely mean different
things now that certainly nvidia has
co-opted the
term so when you hear ray tracing or rtx
cards today
they're applying the same core concept
shooting rays of light through a 3d
space
but what they're doing that's different
is instead of using the rays to produce
a 3d projection
they're normally using the rays to add
lighting to already rendered 3d
polygonal meshes
they're good they use rays that bounce
from one surface to the next changing
the way light and color is output
in the resultant image it's really
really clever it's really resource
hungry
and instead of just scanning left to
right they literally cast rays for every
pixel
actually the way that they optimize your
performance in modern times
is they sub sample an image so they take
a lower resolution render
they then cast the rays across every
single pixel of that
lower resolution render not just
for each horizontal column and then they
upscale the result that's ray
over the sampled image to enhance the
render quality
of a larger or higher res scene so it's
really cool they basically use the same
kind of
ai upscaling you see when people take
old movies and upscale them to 8k
if you're interested in this i'd really
recommend watching the digital foundry
teardowns
of quake 2 rtx um so it's a port that
nvidia produced to demo their rtx cards
where they made a real-time ray traced
version of quake
and you can see the digital noise
floating around it's really excellent
so i want to leave you with a small
anecdote about a question i had when i
was 10.
i remember trying to play doom on an
underpowered 486 and struggling with
performance
one of the options was to reduce the
size of the window that was built into
the game you could shrink
literally the rendering window and it
would go faster
similarly i also played a lot of doom on
the 32x
as one of the several owners of that
short-lived mega drive add-on in the uk
it too rendered in a smaller window i
remember wondering to myself
why is it faster to run doom when you
reduce the viewable game size
and in writing this talk i realize that
of course it's because there are less
pixels to render so doom's bsp engine
wasn't a raycaster but it had similar
performance constraints
and by simply reducing the screen real
estate the rendering sped up
so i hope this talk has inspired you to
try and work on something you didn't
think you could do
i approached this topic with the
trepidation of someone that hadn't
studied maths in
half my life to any particular high
level
and i had a lot of fun working out all
the details on the way i'd literally
i'd never written a 3d render of any
kind before i'm not a graphics
programmer
but i want to remind everyone that
programming for fun and not just for
your job is totally okay
like do fun things you're going to love
it
i'm available on all of the internet
tweet at me tell me i know nothing
tell me i forgot your favorite game tell
me you love me ask for the code i'd love
to hear from you um and i really want
you to all enjoy
the rest of the conference uh thank you
very much